are they bringing covid back well it
sort of seems like it uh yesterday on
our show because the view was on at the
same time as us Brock let me know that
live on The View they announced that
whoopee has copied
um as you can see Whoopi is not here she
has covid
yes it's back it's back it's back but
she's on the mend she's on the tail end
and she'll probably be back this week
but sorry she's not here for those of
you who are looking forward to seeing
her whoopee has covered
that's good guys that's good these
acting lessons you're taking they're
really doing well um so whoopee's got
covered if that Joy is like oh she'll be
back in a couple days it's like what
happened to you gotta lock down you
gotta stay in a room you gotta wrap a
plastic bag around your head with duct
tape and the whole thing anyway so okay
that's just Whoopi having covet at the
season debut of the view but it does
seem like the machine is kind of trying
to scare everybody
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]